that's so good mmm that little bit of
sweetness like kicks this savory dish up
a notch
that's such high talk about Taco Bell
[Music]
today we're gonna be swapping snacks
while being drunk and high very high
very high this is very good drunk
there's something so real about how to
the drun cheese is what I call the drunk
munchies love that
yeah dren cheese and then the munchies
that's over there another word we do you
call it when your eyes
I don't like hun cheese as much hon
cheese isn't is fun I'm French cheese we
are currently sober but we're about to
get drunk and or high and then uh eat
some food your go to fast food yeah
Crunchwrap supreme hands-down it's the
best it has everything inside it that
you could ask for in a bite and it's
also from Taco Bell so it's great that's
true Taco Bell the most vegan friendly
fast food place did you know that I
didn't know that it is my go-to is the
opposite of that
chick-fil-a that's when we have veganism
and polarizing radical politics balance
the other thing which you'd blame tons
of sauces like you have your chick-fil-a
sauce which I mean dips are the most fun
part of snacking
it is so you pick talked about I picked
chick-fil-a right right this is so fun
[Music]
Wow
so good it's so good I'm usually not a
fan of Crunchwrap Supremes because I
don't like taco bell tomatoes when I'm
drunk I don't notice the mush and I'm
like can I ask you a question you please
do not like Taco Bell sauces but we have
all these chick-fil-a's would you do a
plain across babe
Wow I love the fact that you just refer
to this as a crossfade and - absolutely
we're drunk in - you guys all right
we did something amazing thank you isn't
it great
oh great Wow now that you're high and
you're trying to get drunk snacks yeah
which would you rather have I would have
Crunchwrap because there's something
about holding a pocket and having it all
stay together through the whole process
that is real satisfying mm I like the
messiness and the options of having
chicken nuggets it's all much rather
drunk me just like pluck away my go-to
hi snack is my childhood on a plate
it is wheat bread with creamy peanut
butter and strawberry cream cheese okay
who hurt you and your childhood to make
you put these things together I like a
good thick spread so for me cream cheese
was always superior to jelly
my junk snack is cup ramen but then you
also make some Hot Cheetos in there
because that way you add some extra
spice and flavor ooh that sounds so good
you just like drop a couple in there and
they just stir it around uh-huh
you just like get in there this sounds
delicious also it's like having spicy
ramen without having spice around okay
okay let's swap swap it out hold out
cheers Cheers
[Music]
this was a thick bike it didn't have
enough strawberry flavoring for look at
that cuz you're used to a sweet Jam
mm-hm that's sweet
I love this this would be a go-to snack
and Robin for me is quick easy simple
delicious but to add the flavor and the
crunch of the hot cheeto that's what
it's all about genius genius I haven't
added bye to my childhood yet we might
need it go for it
yo this is like not how I remember
[Music]
yeah I'm pretty disappointed in this
okay I'm glad now that I know that it is
no longer a part of your childhood
memory I do not like you that much word
this is not that good it's not I'm glad
you have shared a childhood memory
however I still would pick the ramen and
hot cheetos over this I'm sorry what
does it say that I would pick yours over
my memories also says that I have better
taste than your memory right riding that
peanutbutter train you really like
peanut butter I love peanut butter I
hope this isn't as depressing as your
last peanut butter is the best condiment
I think I love Nutter butters I think
they're real fun bite and I think that
they're also like a fun thing to break
apart so I picked Nutter butters I've
been Torrijos as a counterpart Ginetta
butters for the same reason because I
feel like they're super difficult this
is brilliant so if you grab the fork you
don't put it on the actual cookie right
you put it in the cream oh you put it in
the cream gently like that uh-huh and
then you would dip it at you see and
then it just soaks and you just drown
the Oreo and you lift it back up and
you're just like you know game crimson
game-changing game changing there's my
favorite drunk ball ever that's a noble
idea
thank you I accept my work okay I like
that bite I did too much rounding
anything I've done with my father is
that crazy crazy was really good Wow
cool crazy
[Music]
I haven't had another butter since I was
a kid yeah and this and the milk clutch
like it was it was a great idea
I like no - butters a lot because it's a
2-byte cookie you know I mean and I feel
like I do love an Oreo especially with a
wider cream base but I do think like
this is a one bite cookie and so for me
I get a lot of mileage out of this and I
like that do you eat less cuz eating no
you just eat it between the two while I
enjoy the Nutter Butter in the milk I
still think I'm gonna go with a classic
Oreo in the snack world
I mean Crunchwrap with polynesian game
changer fork on a cookie game-changer
hot cheetos with ramen game-changer and
in mine it was like peanut butter that
Crunchwrap supreme into chick-fil-a
sauces stupid like I'm like I would
never thought to put those things
together and I'm like this might be
something I mean I'm still drunk still
higher yeah I'm still high let's just
get more food done and done